this video describes a device that can
capture the human figure through walls
using RF signals we place our device
behind the wall and it can see the
silhouette of a person who walks in an
adjacent room the device works correctly
even if the room is completely closed
for example if a person stands behind
the wall the device will output looks
like this in particular the output on
the right shows the background in navy
blue and the various human body parts in
red orange and yellow here we can see
the person's head chest ons and feet how
does this work
the device operates by transmitting
wireless signals that traverse the wall
reflect off the human body and come back
at every point in time only a subset of
human body parts reflect the signal back
to the device here we show the output of
the device as the person walks at
different points at time different parts
of the human body reflected signal and
the device captures multiple snapshots
at various points in time it then
combines these snapshots through a
reconstruction algorithm that allows the
device to recover the human silhouette
through the wall here we can see the
person's head chest arms and feet the
device can distinguish between different
people behind the wall so for example
over here we ask two different people to
stand behind the wall and this is the
output of our device by training on
different subjects we can use a
classifier to distinguish between them
the device can also distinguish between
certain human posters if the person
stands straight the output looks like
this well when someone stands in other
posters the devices output reflects his
posters
the device can also track human limbs
from behind the wall here we show a
scenario where a person draws a shape in
the air and we show the output of our
device to the right the device can trace
the person's hand with high accuracy we
compute the device's output to that of a
connect placed directly in front of the
person and show the connects output in
red in comparison to connect our median
error is around two centimeters for more
information on how the device works
check out our project webpage